bro there is no quick question i'd
rather have my knees not bad i don't
have my arms bro you are not thinking
about getting through you're not
thinking it through you're just going
like oh no wrong
that'd be nice but but no
[Laughter]
and then you're sweating but you can't
wipe your own
[Laughter]
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying gang gang buzz bug
sword
so eric you had the one of the cops on
who actually no i did george lopez's
podcast and oh and he had him yeah he
they no they do a podcast together oh oh
damn yeah they do a podcast
it's a cop what are they like i don't
even know this guy talk about after
you're done talking about the
nightstalker yeah he just i was so
fascinated i just kept asking him
questions about what yeah but so every
episode's about the night stalker this
is about like a true crime and that kind
of it is yeah george lopez does yeah oh
that's hilarious but it just gets in the
box most handsome serial killer of all
time i don't know man especially
when he got his teeth fixed yeah he
didn't go i think jeffrey died forgot
him no you're gonna say ted but i don't
know
he's the one jeffrey
yeah
i think ed gaines was really attractive
yeah big guy
all right [ __ ] mary kill
[Laughter]
don't ask them
i would like to ask him if it was yeah
yeah yeah okay
about the nightstalker though uh you
know this is in the 70s and he would
creep through the windows and at the
time the police stations didn't talk so
they couldn't figure out that he was
killing all these people in different
areas
but
he you couldn't have the night stalker
in 2022 because everyone has air
conditioning nobody leaves their windows
open he ain't creeping through my door
without everybody with that ring who's
that on the left ed that is him yeah huh
i'm not scared i'm [ __ ] is that
something i'm talented
um
and the guy in the right uh the
nightstalker looks like theo
wow theo and brian callan right there
let's do it on brian uh i mean
yeah
i mean it feels like there's
asses in the back that'd be me right
that's theo's kid if he had a baby in
the background
remember he's gonna have oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you you uh you're attractive or what you
think am i attracted yeah to am i
attracted to them no you're attractive
right you got a good shirt on and you
got to [ __ ] your forehead's nice too
dude oh you like the four no you're just
an attractive guy oh thanks man
i'm an la-6 nah dude you're not you're
you're more than that it's it's annoying
[Laughter]
your forehead and it it like slopes down
in like a nice way and like you you got
browsed and they're pronounced and it's
just
go [ __ ] yourself
interesting good though it works
it works
oh yeah no it was like this movie
somebody sent it to me oh yeah i saw
that guys i'm stressed out man i'm gonna
be in [ __ ] dallas what the [ __ ] gotta
go to crystalia.com for tickets jesus
christ just been weighing on me oh i got
the dopest freaking hat for you for
dallas you don't want is it a cowboy hat
uh i mean i have a cowboy if you want
there you are right there that's that is
are you kidding me you you you for real
being real you dress like that yeah yes
you you have a hat like that oh yeah i
got another one coming too from daisy
with an oversized jacket what [ __ ] what
is this hat that you're gonna get from
daisy may and what is daisy may daisy he
makes custom hats like those daisy is
his name no oh it's just a yeah that's
his brand daisy mate so he makes hats
for like zz top he just made a a collab
with uh post malone like he's bro oh
okay cool cool yeah cool he's dope so
does he go to chrisley.com to get
tickets to dallas or no whoever right
anyone anywhere
he was like i'm trying to figure out how
to get tickets uh in dallas crystal
ladies like but i'm so annoyed because i
gotta be in baltimore august fourth
through the sixth at your shows
in baltimore next week thursday friday
saturday i'm in baltimore and then he
goes and what's crazy about that is that
wichita chrisley.com you gotta go to
wichita no no no no he didn't say that
where he goes dude i'll be in chicago
august 26th one night only at the den
theater because you're there oh okay
okay and then i told him i said get
tickets at fakeboy.com yeah so he didn't
say anything about atlanta or dc
chrisley.com atlanta oh it's september
9th okay cool so anyway oh wow there it
is dude
that's you wow that's like you dressed
up as that guy for halloween
unbelievable his nose is better though
yeah uh well you know who is that guy
honestly and i'll be at la jolla wow
so saturday so sad no answer knife
no energy
well i had to look
during comic con oh yeah how was it dude
it was lit you been there that's the
reason i did the club because i featured
for you there yeah great club live
factory san diego but dude comic con i
thought it was like kids like teenagers
oh bro bro there's people like eric
dressed up as [ __ ] popeyes there's
people dressed up as eric yeah bro
it's it's [ __ ]
we saw seven they say movies
dude it is an insane thing i went to
comic-con when i was in eighth grade and
it was just one room bro it was just one
room with a like a few booths and like i
would get the guy's signatures and bro
it is
unbelievable now man yeah back then it
would be like those kind of dudes that
walk on hollywood boulevard yeah yeah
dressed as spider-man with a fanny pack
yeah
yeah
bro like hot chicks dressed up as [ __ ]
no way dude back then no way no no it's
like movie quality outfits well like
like they had chris pratt there i think
they had all the big ones there but they
had uh yeah when they had uh what's his
name uh who's the guy from breaking bad
uh the main guy uh brian crazy they had
brian cranston dressed as brian cranston
remember he had the
do you hear about this he had the mask
on and he was walking around like the
brick and bad guy and then he was he
walked up on the podium and he took it
off it was really him and everyone was
like what it was
funny i i didn't realize how big it was
it was chaos yeah it's really bad it's
crazy bro
it's crazy yeah this part right here
realized too they were incredibly
realistic heisenberg mask that people
realized who they were bumping into he
said he walked the floor in the mask
trying to use a higher voice pretending
to be a fan it's not funny so it was fun
meeting you and you met me
yep and that's how this isn't that funny
i've never seen that [ __ ] you know i do
it feels like oh it's really good very
cool dude oh wow
you know when i watched it over the uh
pandemic and you loved it it's the best
show has ever been yeah you're crazy it
is it is but you know what i feel this
energy though because sometimes i was
two years late on it because when people
start talking i just watched it i know
but when people start talking about
something
yeah yeah like i still haven't watched
uh mad men
i think that's a comedian thing because
you are like i'm not gonna be a part of
whatever anyone else is yeah you know
everyone's going that way i go this way
yeah i do that too i was six years later
on game of thrones
i made fun of dragons for years yeah
yeah yeah
i watched it i watched i i i watched
three seasons i i think i might even
watch four and i was like
when does it i'm i'm i'm not good
when does it what when does it
get
good
god you're the worst
but you like breaking bad
yeah it's great it's the best job with
breaking bad hold on so uh he's going to
sell uh whatever meth cook my teacher
wife has cancer all right got it
no you're allowed
are you kidding i went like this
come on man that is so crazy talk about
the
oversimplification yeah check please
dude the acting when he i'm not going to
spoil it but please do nothing
but when he's on the phone at the it's
like one of the last episodes talking to
his wife yeah and saying yeah was saying
the thing about how like you had nothing
to do with it and you know you did and
he's bro he's only admitted like
oh there's a different
level of acting yeah he i go oh i'll
quit hollywood oh mr acting's easy yeah
remember yeah remember no no no no no no
no no no but most of it no no most of it
i'm with him most of it
his part he can't play that part i mean
nobody could play that part christian
bale him bring up my scene from i'm
dying up here
barry
bale that guy and eric griffin christian
bear dude i know you're not going to see
this movie i know he's so great people
say he's so great in thor he is so good
in thor i'll see that movie
here's two villains
the dude that was in wonder woman two
the that guy that plays the villain in
wonder woman two he shouldn't have been
in the movie because he was so good like
he was bringing stuff to this world like
yo dude
this is wonder woman like you tone it
down there it is that guy's so good and
christian bill was that good okay
woman two who was the guy i wonder why
wonder woman i saw wonder woman one it
was fine no no i saw what i'm saying the
guy that was the villain i know i'm just
asking he was a great
yeah he was what i'm saying is he was
out of place eric he was out of place he
was so bad that guy's a great actor yeah
but it was he was okay in that yeah
he was just so happy because there was
nothing around him to support it let me
tell you something right now okay
the move is out of place the movie the
gray man is bad ryan gosling is
phenomenal in it that's different bro
wonder woman 84 is so bad that nobody's
good in it i thought the guy was good
gray man is fine wonder woman 84 one of
the worst movies i've ever seen
it's insane
take a note from [ __ ] stranger things
you go high during the [ __ ] but
that's when i get out because i can't in
your invisible jet we built this city
we built it well she just but but i
think this is uh on the toilet invisible
jet [ __ ] we built this city wait
wait wait i think this is part of the
problem we get to this guy's no
definition face no no no no yeah this
guy is it
wow
he has no cheek structure he's got no
ears from
foreheads the thing is
when my son draws humans this is what
they look like there's no ears but hold
up though this guy's got
[Laughter]
he's got
this is this is also the real life
quagmire from family down dude hold on
here bring it up here or a little bit
further back his ears on the back
like a dover pincher
dude you touched it
walking behind
his ears are touching yeah yeah yeah far
back his ears are touching he's a
handsome dude though
i'm so sorry dude you're watching
i apologize but you are a character and
somehow he's still he's still got it
yeah he's he's a good looking dude yeah
he's definitely good
fanny pack change all right what's up
hey chris let's take a little break from
just talking about nothing cool because
i'm tired of that are you tired of that
this sounds more interesting it is more
interesting because you like money right
love it that is bills and then you're
such a big how do i make more money
though easily dude i'm talking about my
friends at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc and this saturday ufc 277 you can
watch the big pay-per-view event you can
watch the calves fight command think
what 7pm pacific this saturday and make
money watching ufc 277 with draftkings
this saturday new customers can bet five
dollars on any fighter to win and get
100 in free bets win or lose want even
more action you can also double your
winnings on a same fight parlay combine
multiple bets like which fighter will
win how long the fight will last and so
much more just place your ufc 277 same
game parlay if it hits you'll win double
draftking's a safe secure reliable and
best of all you can deposit withdraw
your money whenever you want download
the draftking sportsbook app right now
use promo code kats bet 5
on any ufc 277 fighter to win and get
100 and free bets no matter what that's
code tats this saturday at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner ufc minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details see next page for directions
disclaimer draftkings we are introducing
bluenile.com the original online jeweler
to high income adults 100k plus a
hundred thousand dollars plus primarily
males 25 plus looking to get engaged or
gift find jewelry to visit the website
and convert into a blue now customer you
know what blue now does dude they sell
all my special moments man by creating
custom engagement rings of his or her
dreams gifting a classic and timeless
jewelry piece what about the prices dude
you won't find it at any jewelry store
man we got you covered man we got you
guys when you're ready to pop the
question you're celebrating a big moment
in your life find julie as unique as she
is with modern
convenience of online shopping at blue
now.com
all right looking for fine jewelry but
having trouble choosing blue now has
jewelry experts on hand twenty four
seven we got you man make your moment
sparkle with jewelry from bluenow.com
and going on right now is the blue now
anniversary sale save up to 40 on
classic fine jewelry pieces and 25
on engagement rings which i i bet you
wish you knew this a little bit yeah i
wish but oh well plus every order it's
insured ships free arrives in discreet
little package so i won't give away
what's inside daddy shop stress free and
find your forever piece go to
bluenow.com today bluenow.com
enjoy
i king queen the steam crew
this is jack from my leg
right now let's go
when he's in that light i'm scared now
chin he came to my restaurant i work out
at the emc i know that's awesome i have
a blast you need to meet him
i have a canister for you
saying hi to random people's babies
while i'm walking around every time i
love babies every time we're just kids i
just want to say hi
but they get nervous sometimes and the
parents i don't know if they like it or
not
what do you think about that
they talking to babies do they have
coconut or allergies keep sniffing walk
well with your weird head structure
yeah yeah
the baby's thinking where are his ears
buzz score this poor guy
let's go he's such a nice guy too alpha
i love you hell yeah bro
yes
he sees this yes dude
in this room
but in this room chris with my mind with
my mind
you could kill me
but with my mind
with my there's something about him
thing with my
my that thing my that your energy dude
if we were on an island you'd be getting
the [ __ ] coconuts bro don't forget
you'd be getting the coconuts
dude this guy don't talk to people's
babies uh you can talk to baby well you
can go high yeah no but i do every time
yeah but okay here's the thing you know
yes
this guy's walking towards you
it's you you you're your wife and your
and calvin's like a little kid you know
and this guy's just walking and he just
stops you in front of you while you're
walking and he just leans into your
video oh well yeah oh my god is that
what he's talking about well that's what
i'm saying yeah that's too much he's
saying any kid any baby
if you're just walking by like oh cute
baby yeah yeah okay fine and i i swear
but if you're just like
hey weirdo who are you imagine if you
did exactly that holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
eric would scare everybody
but if it's a grown man by himself i'm
like catch a predator you know what i'm
saying
yeah i mean it depends their energy dude
anything more than oh hi hey buddy oh
what you got you got a cool shirt
anything more than that you know but
don't touch them well no definitely
don't touch them dude
by the way rule number one first of all
hey cool shirt to a baby i'm just saying
well maybe they got like a race car
conversations with a baby like [ __ ] off
man hey a cool shirt where'd you get it
that's why my son is advanced
i talked to him like a [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] he's got a race car
and his shirt or something you go oh
nice yeah you move on though yeah yeah
yeah
this is this is chin's
the chicagoland area i got a debate club
for you so back in the day he used to
joke about chris running his dogs oh
yeah um for pictures on instagram or
social media
i think he was kidding until kevin was
born right we haven't seen those dogs
since with something like sand and
butter or something like that yeah we
haven't seen him on chris's instagram
that's true
the big club is was chris actually
renting
social media
um i got one for you big money crystalia
look at that field
he's like old he's like 12. but uh let
me know hit me up uh anyways love what
you guys are doing
gang buzz buzz
bring your dogs to work i should you
know what's funny bro sting it
sting watch the dogs to work out yeah
yeah you know what's funny is that okay
so so kids by the way so yeah i do i
have four dogs okay right now yes i have
i have sam butters which i've had them
for 12 years too many right those are
the ones i have your first wife i don't
know if it's real
those are the ones that theo says that i
rented okay then i you know got with
kristen she had a dog and that's cooper
that's a big dog okay then we found a
dog which i've talked about on my
podcast congratulations going over and
subscribed to supercall and well i
haven't posted about them in a long time
bro yeah look at that kid now so [ __ ]
them dogs no so yeah i don't even see
like it's like you actually oh no those
are the other two those are the other
two this is hilarious though but they're
two of the four so we can get it you
know
we're gonna do that we're gonna see if
you are this is so funny watch this
cooper on the right and chen's aka trash
dog on the left we'll see what good boys
you are what's that i like his ears
snack challenge watch us sit sit watch
us sit
no
no
because there's a food on the ground no
you see it
you put a little tree down cooper's such
a good boy
now what this is the dog after him is
the dog that we found
what a good boy he is right yeah can we
edit a little bit of this nah bro you
keep the whole thing in cinematic good
boy you're a good boy now watch this now
we do the chance thing
now we found chens in panoramic look at
this [ __ ] already
now you take the trash panda
no
no
he's like what
he's like i'm never gonna see food
now i do have those dogs now okay the
other day so here's the thing calvin has
become my whole life i'm not gonna put
pictures of the dogs right by the way
cut to like if you would have pain to
the right his two dogs that he owns are
just sitting there like this
what happened to us
so hold on old news so hold on so i got
the [ __ ] um
[Music]
so so i came home the other day and my
and kristen was acting kind of i always
talk about how i don't like think about
the dogs and how like i i haven't fed
the dogs in years she does it you know
or my assistant or something right
so it's a joke that like you don't give
a [ __ ] about the dogs so kristen uh
was being weird the whole time and like
taking video of me
and
uh an hour later she took video of me
and she was like do you notice anything
different and i was like what and she
was like do you notice how quiet it is
and i was like what are you talking
about and she was like is there anything
different going on right now and i was
like no oh yeah it is kind of quiet and
she was like could you think about what
it might be
and she got on video i should post it
but she was like the dogs aren't here
and i was like oh yeah dude i don't even
[ __ ] think about the dog
i didn't even know how [ __ ] horrible
is that my assistant had him and [ __ ]
she was there they they're there
that's probably the last one
though what do i say i'll just say
helper
helper
that's a word out that's way worse isn't
it you could say the help
oh that's help what are you like oh what
is this 1805 my dogs
the help took the dogs for the day
that's bro that's uh butters yeah i do
still have the dogs but uh i just don't
post about him yeah you're right i mean
mike mike brings his dog here the thing
about mike's dog who's you know head of
thick boy production his dog is 79 years
old blind he's got cancer in sick spots
it might just keep his thing alive he's
like bro let me go yeah he might just
keep just
trying to like you get food out and he
just he can't see and he has no teeth
and he just kind of like looked for it
he's a real vibe killer yeah
who's talking about mike
it's like you you're having some fun
with this
you're kind of like oh man oh man this
is a downer
and you're
keeping your sick dog alive dude
on the back of his feet like his hips
have gone again
dude
just 90. but he has he wears two crocs
on the back of his [ __ ] legs why he
gets like you skate across that dog you
know what that dog i've seen
that dog's gonna have a leash on him and
then jump over a fence and just hang
himself that happened once and my uncle
told me about that story this dog
[ __ ] jumped
[Laughter]
you're bad
dude
my uncle is a [ __ ] insane person he
always tells us [ __ ] like this is like
dude i know a dog that hung himself and
he jumped this is like a theo story and
the dog [ __ ] uh was on the leash
jumped over a fence and didn't and and
was hanging
wasn't trying to get out it was just
like
jesus how awful this ac dog [ __ ] the
other person see the dog hung himself on
the thing like it's the [ __ ]
handmaid's tail on the wall yeah
oh jesus you watch handmaid's tale i i'm
trying to again another depressing show
yeah it's like i'd rather watch that
show first season's fine it's no it's
all yeah the first season's fine because
you're depressed it takes 12 episodes to
realize how [ __ ] not really that good
it is
it's so boring because you're like
you're like all right all right taking
this okay okay and then you're like okay
and you go all right i'm out then do it
if it's gonna take [ __ ] it's like
wins i watched one season i was out with
what shows do you like
well i mean obviously breaking bad
sopranos let me see what's the problem
is there no new show that you yeah hold
on there is i i started watching um
ah [ __ ] i i honestly have the worst
memory uh bates motel
hotel it's fine
my favorite show ever to watch was lost
to watch now i know i understand that
that's not like at the level is breaking
bad and honestly yeah thank you but to
watch it i'd to watch it and to keep
flipping the next one next one yes
exactly that was like the original like
serial long binge watching yeah yeah in
the end i just i never watched it like
stupid as [ __ ] but the uh the ending
everyone got all upset about right there
it fades to black
it's not bad oh and these are hard yeah
yeah 100 people on game of thrones
season 8 i loved it's my favorite scene
was terrible there you go
that's the narrative yeah unbelievable
unbelievably bad the last disagree uh
they got lazy capture capture is a good
show uh on peacock much boring stuff huh
no that's bbc bbc's killing it dude
honestly you don't watch yellowstone
1883.
come on dude i don't watch it yet i'll
wait a few years i wait till it's over
and to see if it held this the test of
time oh you know it wasn't then i
watched that one oh man
there's like a hole in the ground it's a
western oh yeah with uh what's his name
roland james yeah
no no josh brolin it's like this like oh
men in black three no no no josh bro
it's called like underworld or some
[ __ ] outer world outer world or
shadow outer range
i saw season one it was good then i
turned on season two sometimes with
these netflix shows with these binge
shows like they wait too long to come
out and i'm like all right i i i forget
what happened bro dude you know what i'm
with you yeah you know you know what's
good is that show dark was that that
german show yeah that show is [ __ ]
good as [ __ ] dude hey hey what i don't
like about
watching hey do you have do you have
anything current dude well that's
because
darkness or something new like not so
niche
i don't know you won't watch breaking
bad yeah bro this guy's
[ __ ] i'm definitely not watching what
are you watching
name a show dude stranger things
is fine narcos is fine but dude they
they need to stop
with the [ __ ] voice over dude
there's so much it's like i know what
i'm watching [ __ ] it's like and
then
you speak spanish no no no well that's
why they have no no no the [ __ ] guy
is like and then the narcos was ahead of
us there and we went to the narcos and
then what the narcos didn't know was we
were four steps ahead of him it's like
dude i'm watching the [ __ ] show
it's like you're watching a show and
someone's next to you and like dude you
guys walking in the [ __ ] i like that
you know why because
you're an idiot that's why
dude you just watch the [ __ ] show
[Laughter]
it's all style baby it's all style
oh man
oh this is my boy austin yeah he's a
great uh music uh musician wow this is
papaya he did the arizona song that made
chris cry
oh yeah you can't listen
ryan is this the scale
chris theo eric who's ever there this
week because
you know you guys are switching it up
um i wanted to get a king of stinging on
my guy my fearless leader
my mentor my professor andrew tate
um he's got a lot of hot takes that kind
of got the internet and a little bit of
a frenzy
some would say he's a little bit sexist
i think he's just dropping knowledge you
don't know what yeah i want to know
that's that funny guy hate
gangnam wait who is he hell yeah
he's he's the he wasn't he a
professional kickboxer yeah he's like a
real ladies man like real alpha
he's i don't know him oh yeah yeah yeah
this guy
is the first one to have him
yeah sugar is the first one to like
bring him to the podcast it was crazy
like on all my social medias in like the
last week all of a sudden he's taking it
right every account he's been in every
show but he's basically a pimp which is
i want to feel respected in the
household okay so i follow him on tick
tock meals i'm assuming well truthfully
i eat out most of the time yeah but this
is actually one of the problems i have i
want you guys to feel sorry for me maybe
with your big channel we can start
charity and get some money going because
you know what happens now
my life you know i'm flying on private
jets i'm eating all these restaurants
i'm driving all these super cars and
it's very hard for me to find a way for
women to show me
respect because they're just like on the
jet duh i go to the restaurant duh
they're in the club duh well that's what
i'm saying you know what i mean and
they're like and most dudes are happy
just get pushed
he goes in and out of the english accent
american right yeah no this guy
this guy's made some [ __ ] phenomenal
points i'll tell you that much
he really has like i mean he i i think a
lot of it is character but like i mean
you know what's his points i mean he'll
do
like about the government and just talk
about [ __ ] yeah everything yeah and i'm
like huh
i've heard of him his big thing is being
uh he uses the matrix as like an analogy
for today's society and you have to
attach you have to detach from the
matrix otherwise you get caught by the
government uh like during coven all the
restrictions but he's become
independently wealthy where he has 11
passports he could fly over all over the
world during covet and he's not like
uh
captive to
societal pressures i don't know because
he has so much money though yeah him and
every rich dude how does he have so much
money uh he his first thing like him and
his brother yeah they managed webcam
girls and now he's like just parlaying
it and he has hustlers at university
which uh i talked to austin he's he
subscribed for 50 bucks a month and he
teaches how to get people out to month
yeah and he's got like
i don't know he's he said on dave horton
show he has 87 000 monthly subscribers
he could totally be lying well everyone
always lies just to get hoes uh
and yeah no be successful yeah oh but
you can sign up for that
just hose good hoes
he's also polarizing because people say
his massages and stuff but he's an
entertainer for sure yeah it's a but
it's an act
yeah
says tom spit coffee out of his nose
yeah here's the here's the part of that
get rid of that
won't respect me crap that's not real is
that real you know what so many women
say to me you're so andrew you know what
you're so rich but you're smart and
you're actually very intelligent and i
know you'd get really bored of like a
robot and i'm sitting there thinking
[ __ ] i wish to god you're a robot
shut the [ __ ] up we think about star
signs oh yeah i'm so glad tell me more
about by sagittarius rising idiots i
don't give a [ __ ] give me your robot all
men want robots that's all we want four
wives robots inshallah put the
put the put the burke on yep what are
you talking about we don't care too
yeah wow yeah you know trip eric's not
affected you're not feeling it
eric's signed up
i have two accounts i have a ghost
account
make sure
yeah
so look uh mma fans i got i got to talk
to you about something i'm glad we took
this break but uh as the fighters face
off during ufc 277 you can take down
your own big win with draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of ufc this saturday new
customers can bet five dollars on any
fighter to win and get
i know it sounds ridiculous but it's
true a hundred dollars in free bets win
or lose oh my god you want even more
action if that didn't get your beak wet
you can also double your winnings on the
same game parlay all right combine
multiple bets like which fighter will
win how long the fight will last and so
much more just place your bets on ufc
277 same fight parley if it hits you'll
win double draftkings is safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit
withdraw your cash whenever you want
daddy download the draftkings sportsbook
app now use promo code cats k-a-t-s bet
five dollars on any ufc 277 fighter to
win and get 100 in free bets no matter
what that's code k-a-t-s katz
this saturday at draftkings sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
ufc minimum age and eligibility that's
always hard to say i struggle with my
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details see you
next page for directions for disclaimer
what up king staying in the wing
and
sitting there i got a debate club for
you fellas today if this guy can't sing
what is more shame morally corrupt
ricky martin
hanging out banging out his nephew
who knows
it's going to be a debate
or the honest guy truth of
elon's dad raw dog and old step daughter
and having a baby that's news to me i'm
gonna go ahead and say yeah
that's a bit weird man he's been going
accepted that as a child
and now you're having a child
so i'm gonna let you fellas aside
nick brendan theo chen mark
chris is this i almost forgot your bud
is this everlasting guys figure this out
for me let me know is that bubba sparks
yeah oh okay so all right so ricky
martin was having a seven month
relationship with his 21 year old nephew
hold on no but his nephew uh reneged on
the deal and was like that i made it all
up yeah i think he stopped pressing
charges he was like dancing i'm not sure
about that one at all but that one i
know yeah he reneged on it was like just
plain i don't think the nephew's denying
that they had a relationship though no
he's denying that he was like raped and
received death threats like multiple
death threats the police said that he
was getting death threats if he showed
up
okay and then elon's dad at 76 confirmed
secret second child with his
stepdaughter so okay hold on let me try
and figure this out so this is two kids
by the way so wait before you figure out
let me let me help you uh ricky martin
the the
nephew
is from his step-sister's side so it's
not blood oh it's not no oh
but they were trying to charge him with
incest and my problem with that
situation let me tell you my problem
with it
now all these details are coming out but
it didn't matter because it was already
sensationalized on the news and he was
like thought of as whatever and and now
it's like you know is he
that's out there yeah definitely that's
damn it here's my thing it's like if if
if this kid
you know adult young adult male is
getting abused or whatever it is like
that if it's real
get the facts it's too important
you can't just put some [ __ ] out
and and and
you know but that's tmz yeah something
they don't give a [ __ ] but that's social
media in a nutshell i know but i get the
story right i think that's the problem
there's no credibility and then also
they blast all [ __ ] out without looking
into it but then also like you guys
didn't know that was uh his step like
he's not even blood related like i'm not
saying it's right but it's not his blood
relative yeah
well that's what happened that only
matters though that only matters when it
comes to like he can't be charged with
incest but here's the thing forget that
it's inappropriate
okay yeah and that's all
that's
he he did something inappropriate and
the kid was involved too so they did
something that was just out of pocket
and that's their business
yeah
the person was 21 how old was he
he's probably like 40 but hold on yeah
you say it's inappropriate but yeah
because it's inappropriate
if i'm ricky martin you know what i'm
saying but then also they're not going
to get clicks like did you guys know
that the
the nephew dropped the charge no because
that doesn't get clicked but how [ __ ]
up is that it doesn't get clicks dude
but not like i say not everybody has
like if ricky martin wants to like you
know sue for defamation or whatever it
is like that not everybody has that kind
of money man you need all of them oh
yeah you need ricky martin money to do
that you need johnny
he probably spent more money on the law
fees than he's going to get back from
her johnny depp yeah but yeah we but
every we i mean
in this community and all the
communities bro you i mean chris brown
everyone's getting this [ __ ] and it's
like
to have that money and fight that [ __ ]
fine but like if you don't have
millions and millions and millions upon
millions of dollars you can't fight that
[ __ ] i know
no yeah and then here's the thing even
if you do fight and you win unless
you're johnny depp if you're just
normal you know like c b list or you
switch for your comic can you beat it
mm-hmm that doesn't get tracked no i'm
not going to report that yeah so it's
really there's no upside so then the
other thing is like i think i believe
that elon musk's father has two kids
with this chick so
for me the second now that because they
have two i don't give a [ __ ] about it
really yeah because they have two one
you're good yeah because that means it's
an established relationship at this
point now and you love each other yeah
you can't just have two kids if you have
one kid
could be what could be right
yeah but
if you have two kids they're in a thing
and they're just like that's why no one
cares yeah so wait okay so what happened
so it's his stepdaughter which means
it's his second wife's uh daughter from
a previous marriage and he's not with
that wife and he had an affair with the
step-daughter and left the mom i don't
know what happened to this frowned upon
too eric where i come from yeah but it's
inappropriate it's inappropriate yeah
but i'm saying that's still a family
business yeah he's like this yeah i'm
living i got my two kids and my girl why
you all care mm-hmm you know what are
y'all yeah okay but how old was she when
they had when they first had uh she was
oh when he met her the girl was four
years old okay
so he was like that
yeah there's a 45 zeal on flying 41. you
elon mars and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like four years old yeah that's
why do you raise that kid and then you
have a affair with her that is creepy
i know but i said elon's worse elon's
dad's worse yeah he's 70 76 and she's 35
right now
i don't know if he was like and the
first baby was 2019 so she was 32. but
they knew each other are they still
together
it looks like it
yeah then it's like oh well they should
have been together not the mom and him
anyway that's hilarious
here's a guess you had to wait you know
what i mean here's the cats in the wild
someone said their dog looks like chris
wow that's [ __ ] funny same forehead
huh
that's funny
where's your hair like that um i was i
got i almost got the part of don't be
drinking your juice in the hood south
central
i actually don't know i think i think i
did that for calvin
oh yeah coolio
look up marlon wayne that's one of the
ways no marlawynne's in the
thing which great movie
um
not probably not a great movie i haven't
seen it but as soon as i said great i
was like oh [ __ ] they have funny moments
yeah do they i don't know i i i i
mean a movie where
like a guy's talking to his kid
but the kid the dad's younger than
you know oh
that's funny there's some funny [ __ ] in
that movie yeah yeah
i used to love spoof movies man
yeah but no but it like naked gun era no
even um not even like scary the first
scary movie hilarious oh i thought it
was funny dude first scary [ __ ] funny
dude come on or the other one is not
another teen movie no she's not good oh
you're crazy that's right not another
team movie it's hilarious i was with you
come on movies no when they go when
they're like looking like they're making
fun of that whatever movie where they're
like all right let here's the bet you uh
you have to make that person the prom
queen and then it's like they go that
guy and it's like a [ __ ] hunchback
dude yeah yeah yeah yeah that's too easy
what about you know yeah the siamese
twins that's too easy then it's like a
girl with a ponytail and glasses ew yeah
yeah
that's funny when you tell it it's not
funny it's not funny in the movie like
yo man i'm no i'm the one black guy
yeah choking black guy i think i'm the
one black guy y'all crazy you got to
watch that no i like no you are funny
telling it all scary movies are pretty
funny too
their dicks are on their fingers and
they didn't realize it and that guy's
talking he just put this in here
and he's going like this
he's like oh they're dicks their penis
are actually on their fingers they come
out it's funny moments man i don't know
to go watch airplane but not if you're
woke if you're woke don't watch it like
airplane couldn't get made today oh no
way you can make it the airplane is so
the thing about that this is the thing
[ __ ] movies ever bro
when they say like oh [ __ ] uh like uh
i'm nervous when he's on the plane
they're like oh yeah you
uh you've have you ever flown wait wait
what is it ever before what is it i'm
nervous
oh yeah i'm nervous and he's on the
place i'm nervous he's the first time he
says no i've been nervous lots of times
like that kind of humor
kills me bro so when the old lady comes
over
the black guy's talking the jive yeah
oh lady comes over it's okay i speak
jive yeah yeah yeah
you can't do that oh my god no you know
never bro that was so funny uh naked
guns so funny leslie nielsen they that
it was a diamond bro he would do that
guy umpire oh [ __ ] bro i want to make it
but they don't do but even the scary
movies and the [ __ ] they weren't like
that really see i want to make jon thick
you know what i mean
it's like are you retired i'm never
working
remember o.j simpson's a naked gun he
had a big part wow yeah
leslie knows mr poopy pants when he did
that
oh [ __ ] so funny who's that leslie
knows his son yeah who is this uh just a
submitter okay cool let's do it this
looks like one of your videos
i'm calling you from victoria bc
uh chris we miss you here man i saw you
a few years ago when you came and it was
amazing
if you come back
you come in the summer time when it's
not so [ __ ] cold yeah it gets up to a
decent temperature i guess
i'm calling you with a debate club today
that me and my girl came up with
would you rather have your knees never
bend again or your elbows never bend
again
oh knees pretty dicey either those are
terrible
options but i think one's less terrible
yeah you have to love to see what you
guys think yeah you would have you had
to be nice some hilarious debates nick
and chin and yeah
yeah like a [ __ ] scarecrow all right
so go ahead work through it go ahead
okay so your arms okay cool how are you
gonna eat you'll never have a private
conversation ever again because he's
always gonna be on speakerphone
uh
you can't wipe your ass you can't drive
you get control just
yeah
you have to be like way far back
walking at least like you can
yeah yeah i agree you can't see you
can't bring you so you're you're not
driving there either
you what car you get where your legs are
yeah you also you couldn't sit in a car
again there's no plane right i think you
could still drive
and you have to sit in the back seat oh
you just put it all the way back and
just use your [ __ ] feeties no you get
one of those like
you people don't have any arms yeah you
have to drive like this yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right bro there is no quick
question i'd rather have my knees
knocked back i don't have my arms bro
you're not thinking you've got to get
through you're not taking it through
you're just going like oh no wrong
[Laughter]
and then you're sweating but you can't
wipe your own
[Laughter]
uh
yeah plus you're gonna pull your
hamstring what the [ __ ] was that you're
gonna pull your hamstring and [ __ ] and
you're not gonna be able to do either
all right yeah you're not gonna be a
massager either way it [ __ ] sucked
well yeah man it sucks this guy couldn't
wipe his head and he should yeah oh wow
he should i got shirts lit
what up my dude
out brandon
for this weekend here in san diego super
dope
i was thinking
in a team setting for debate for
two more push-ups
stealing chris
or brendan and
he's my photographer in san diego he's
really tough oh yeah he's good um
he's a photographer he doesn't know much
about audio you can't really do a video
with so much [ __ ] that's why he's a
photographer
he's cool dude uh
yeah
you and you and theo
the weakest link it would be me and
theo's the weakest link so it just
depends on how many push-ups can you do
versus him because he would have to do
more push-ups than you to make up for it
to make up for it
but i i mean feel worked out i can do
some push-ups
but also are you i know you're really
strong but you're also very big so it
would push up your thing pretty good at
push-ups oh okay okay i like the
confidence that you came with okay
um and how many would i have to do i
think i could get 25 in yeah then if
you're really good at push-ups you get
25. what's good well i wonder if it's
what's good
you can do right now not as i mean i've
been slacking so
i but theo could could get do probably
do a bunch
you think you can do a bunch yeah the
upper body's
that's true thing which is unfair but
can we do it next tuesday i'll put it
i'll put it out man i'm down
i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] my nose you know
pressure
my nose let's do a push-up cup i know
your nose my nose is still healing
hey let's do a push-up contest thank you
my nose
chris and this guy do a headbutt yeah i
mean this guy dude
you know your angles buddy bro
my god know your angles
shaving those armpits
[ __ ] first foreign
it's the most uncomfortable feeling ever
well why didn't you go out
it's a little disgusting you know what
i'm more than my guard guy myself yeah
there you go buddy man
he shaved his armpit maintenance that's
what he's talking about yeah maintenance
he said you just let it grow out or you
shave it i have to shave mine yeah you
don't want you don't want the there's
nothing but i just can't shave it if you
have to pull it like when it's bald no i
just get my like you know the little
whatever trimmer just sprinkles
trim it i trim it i get mine a philly
fade oh i've never trimmed my armpits in
my life because you don't really grow a
lot of hair there not but he's hairy no
no not there my bottom half is crazy bro
jumanji in my butthole for real it's so
crazy my butthole is insane kevin hart
the rock and that chick from the marvel
movies in there
and whoever else was in that movie you
never just uh want to take like a
the three guard to that [ __ ] like the
the taint nah but like um no because you
can't really see it you can't see it bro
it's patchy right
package
who you can't see back there yeah what
do you have like a webcam setup
what have your girls
[Applause]
when you're hairy you're just hairy and
it's stupid like i'm a hairy guy so it's
like
dumb to like what you know certain you
like it's like at a certain point it's
like it is what it is
yeah yeah you know so like i try to get
this area upper back
you know unreal yeah
random patches yeah yeah yeah and i have
like like right above my butt i have
like patches duck tail yeah i mean so i
gotta get that's because i got a back
injury
please stop sneezing i'm gonna hurt my
back and i got it so are your shoulders
hairy eric yeah just not majorly here
yeah like andre
no no no
i don't it's just like i have weird back
patches which just sucks so it still
does nick back patches and they just
keep springing up like every day
so i just stand in the shower naked and
then rachel just
wow dude that's marriage right there
backpack you're just chilling here you
go rachel we got another one
and then you're here in the background
yeah when they shave them from monsters
such a dad reference but in monsters
they shave the hairy guy oh yeah it's
just like that wow
king interesting it for you guys moving
into an apartment before you have
furniture i moved into this apartment
like four weeks ago i still don't have a
couch but um i got this from my living
room
oh that's [ __ ] hilarious bro don't
ask me what
also like the opportunity to call out
theo
okay theo we've seen stevie weeby with
the wrestling match we've seen it okay i
want you in a wrestling match i'll drive
to nashville i'll come to l.a it doesn't
matter i think i could take you i've
seen you train i see you training all
the time he's
that's such a dude to not have a couch
but have your motorcycle in the living
room i'll tell you that's a dude i have
a buddy of mine just watching the tv on
the [ __ ] motorcycle yeah no that's
definitely how long will pretend he's
not gonna wrestle theo and lick his
[ __ ] yeah right right right um my
buddy just got his bike stolen right in
front of his place uh bike like bicycle
or like no no like that yeah his other
friend had a ducati that got stuck
they're just it doesn't matter what
they're just taking them yeah and here's
the thing too the technology
the laws haven't caught up to technology
right because his other friend put a
error tracker on it and told the cops
here it is yeah it's in this and they
what they do is they put them in
apartments just like that oh so they
don't get jacked yeah they can't no i'm
saying but they're thieves they take it
they stole that in the apartment
oh so they can't come in and get it yeah
it can't come oh yeah they can't see it
oh yeah [ __ ] that's how they look
showing
listen we've had 19 people get shot in
the face no they don't even say that
they go to it they have 19 people shot
in the face and we don't even care about
that i know but here's the thing though
that what i'm saying though is like you
you know
you guys defunded the police they need
to just have like a the the laws or need
to upgrade to like you know it should be
a kind of thing it's like if i have a
tracker on my bike and i can show you
that it's right here that should be
probable cause yeah but the technology
moves so quick that the laws can't move
that way yeah yeah you can't well laws
don't even move at all well right yeah
yeah yeah i just got freed right right
right right right right you're not but
yeah
i by the way but getting back to this
guys
i
remember
when i first moved into
my uh
my last place i didn't have furniture
either and i just i was like i was so
excited i love it yeah to be empty and
that was like hell yeah dude you always
feel like i made it no matter what tv
with a playstation on the ground
there you go real bachelor pad that's
super [ __ ] dude i love it
hey guys
the cross family here we have a debate
club question for you
the pool versus the beach
we need to talk about there's so many
factors here
okay where is the beach that's community
pool yeah let's say a ymca community
pool okay like where's the beach okay
and that question too is it your pool um
ah okay yes true yeah i would say well
anywhere where you don't have to deal
with [ __ ] sand in your anus is great
right it's a plus so you don't go to the
beach food you bring food to the beach
you're all obviously like you get that
[ __ ]
you're like oh
just at the beach though
uh what well no no no i went you know
you [ __ ] up right what do you mean by
going no i'm saying you're you're
stinging the beach but no i still no i'm
they're saying but it's the bait club so
if my son wasn't going to beat to go to
the beach because whatever for my son
okay but sin and ass and all yeah dude
i'll put sin in it
okay me too but uh my son was gonna go
beat we go to the beach dude yep okay
now
i try to convince him maybe we go to him
okay if we got to go to a community pool
then you go to the beach sting it rich
you go to
when
the
beach
to the beach my hair's crazy right now
your hair is [ __ ] insane uh if it's a
community pool uh
sting that because i grew up in
community pools you do pee pee in there
oh your boy [ __ ]
illegal
not when you're six baby god dude
it's cute
so much about
the you know nope see you don't know the
background you don't know the background
i went away there's no we don't need to
know any background yeah
justification no no there is no no we
got a new segment hero or not listen
this we grew up my dad would drop us off
right he's working nine to five so every
summer he dropped us off at the ymca
they used to force us to swim every
[ __ ] day after about three weeks just
swimming that we didn't want to do my
brother older me goes you know what you
should take a [ __ ] in the pool i bet we
don't have to swim i go all right i
gotta take a big old [ __ ] so i swam to
the deep end and then my brother was
like all right you do it and then we do
it just wink at me and i'll yell turd so
i took a big hot [ __ ] and he yelled turd
nobody had to swim for the rest of the
summer your boy was camp
mvp hero or not
first of all
do you think there's any part of that
story
is like
that's gangster that's gangster you
could be a six-year-old gangster like
that's my older brother
hold on a second okay so you're gonna
sit in the pool for max hold honestly
would you have [ __ ] in the pool for matt
i would have had matt do it for me and i
will tell you this dude
[Laughter]
i'm a goddamn ymca legend for this oh my
god i will tell you this dude
imagine you got two kids all right now
we've got kids you'll have kids when you
have a kid it's a little different
there's stuff that you feel about the
kid you realize yourself and the kid and
you're proud of the kid for a lot of
different things now look at it this way
dude okay so
you've got two kids and one of the kids
shits in the pool now on its face that's
bad okay
but terrible then when the kid says
dude i did it for my brother
because i didn't want he didn't want to
swim anymore and i have his back yes
then there's a secret sense of pride
that you have yep
i think this is the secret sense of
pride that you have because your son is
looking out for your other sibling for
their other sibling and that's some nice
that's some game of thrones [ __ ]
honestly first of all it's a brilliant
move people thought it was a baby first
of all his brother did that
to make his stupid little brother
[ __ ] in public
this wasn't for any kind of heroism he
was like i bet you i can get my he
probably told his friends i bet you i
can get brenda to [ __ ] in the pool
secret pride for the prank that's how we
know eric didn't have brother girl
because my brother was like bro we don't
want to you know we don't want to swim
this is how we got to get out of this we
didn't swim so you're further father
so what so what what what what did you
guys do nobody knew it was me daddy come
on bro you're a bet you were a bad kid
he was a bad kid no no no you were a
good down homie you're a bad kid no
you're a down-ass homie
right but you're a bad kid bro
it was you it got out
now
why i'm saying hey you're the one that's
in the pool in 1994.
wow you're gonna find out somebody lost
their sight
oh wow yeah this guy
what's up king sting and the wing and
the sing
i heard the beast chilling i mean the
most regular tattoos
turning up getting drunk he's got a
devil in an eight ball knowing you got
to pregnant dd
to drive you home
gang gang buzz buzz sore
eric i'm not feeling woo woo because
there's too many people out here ain't
gonna embarrass myself
you're already embarrassing yourself
yeah i think the tattoos
you don't want to embarrass yourself you
have on a dumb ass hat
with your pregnant wife while you're on
the phone like
talking to us talking to us look at this
oh my god this guy's a trip he said i
ain't fit to do it man and this is why
we don't go to the beach there it is
right there there you go man he's not
gonna get chris in the background with
calvin yeah yeah but
to eric's point depends on the beast it
depends on the beast yeah that beach
doesn't look nice yeah this isn't the
beach and she's just trying to
just rest
he say hey you're gonna drive me home
i'm about to get hammered
yeah wow that's [ __ ] uh
oh god that whole thing is such a mess
yeah that was that was very problematic
this whole video
i don't know i'm not into it this guy's
got a ton of energy all right let's see
hey guys this is gabriel calling from
hottest balls arizona
um
whose hand is board games if you king it
which is the best board game
thank you guys have a great day first of
all he has the thickest fingers whose
hand is that that's not his hand someone
else went in there yeah like that's
somebody's got on like a
baseball glove
oh that hit his fingers
he's only got three fingers i think is
that right
there's like a cartoon he's a cartoon
did a cartoon called
yeah is that homer simpson's hand dude
check out how thick his pinky is it's a
big toe
mickey mouse is next to him just like
let me know what you need me
when you get an itch his hand looks like
a hamburger and then five bratwurst
[ __ ]
god he got he must be that fire bro that
pinky is like oh my god he's like that
guy the arm wrestling champ with the big
ass hands you know what i'm talking
about yeah
um like three of brendan's ears
zero board games b-o-r-e-d that's how
you spell it zero zero dude games are
fun zero
who don't want to have a conversation
and laugh thank you very much next one
dude boring dude i can't stand board
games that's what [ __ ] people who
don't have personalities do yes we
figured it out next one are you kidding
me i used to play a board game with my
mom all the time it called aggravation
it was this marble board game and it was
one of one of my fondest memories oh
that's sweet too bad you guys didn't
[ __ ] talk
you you just sat with your parents and
just talked that's why i'm so [ __ ]
interesting these days oh my god i'm i'm
i i got bill's number okay
i like a good game of monopoly
oh
it takes too long though yeah that was
it oh you don't like that it's not i
guess it's not board game but remember
the surgery game where you'd have the
tweezers you touched the sides
operation the only game happy hippo the
only
games i'm willing to play are any games
where you don't have to like
[ __ ] keep track or write down or like
build or like if i go can i think about
can i think it what what number am i at
right now six okay i'm at nine i'm not
filling [ __ ] out with those jerky
[ __ ] small pencils that are never
sharp i'm not [ __ ] keeping a list of
[ __ ] i'm not building anything i don't
want it
for you jenga too stressful i'm chilling
my personality is fancy dude and we can
talk all day long but the second you
gotta have me build [ __ ] first of all is
anyone else talking when you're doing or
is it just you doing a performance it's
a lot of that but i will say
yeah it's fun just for chris yeah yeah
he doesn't want to play board games
because he's like i'm the monopoly right
here i got a new bib for everybody
they're like hey chris we shut up for a
second yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude but a [ __ ] dude i do
it for professionals so congrat happy
dude you get this for free now dude i'm
just talking god this is my job him at
thanksgiving as a kid everybody's just
like going like this
chris is doing a performance everybody
yeah
yeah everybody else was playing monopoly
yeah they're like what about hello my
baby
bro there's no demons and spirits that
are moving the [ __ ] it's you i don't
like your attitude i don't like your
attitude you're [ __ ] people
that brought it up hey let's play let's
do ouija they're the one going like this
yeah
yeah
they're like oh there's spirits in this
house like this was built in [ __ ]
three years ago this house
why do you keep coming back to this
[ __ ] i don't know i thought you guys
wanted to talk about it and then uh it's
interesting
here's my thing about goats and michael
jordan same thing there you go there we
go wow wow and then eric has the goat
yeah i'm the goat okay well g.o.i.t goat
grace of all time
we actually do have that it's a weird to
bring a goat on stage right
like you the the fans tell you who's the
goat you can't decide
that's amazing
definitely post that at my walmart that
is fantastic
and just say a bunch of goats oh first
of all [ __ ] you but that's [ __ ]
that's funny
goat
that's it all right well we did it kevin
hart has leather pants on well if
there's anybody that's going to wear
leather pants by the way though i wish i
could pull them off those panda dunks
are those kind of dude i can't even tell
you how many [ __ ] panda dunks were
when i was in london that's all i saw
the panda does yeah yeah yeah we're
talking about chappelle no uh chris
rocks just no no not chris rocks [ __ ]
uh kevin hart you're both racist
and then chris ross goes on why does
chris rock have on we're racist against
ghosts because he's like everybody
there's black no those are those convert
what the [ __ ] are those
oh no i was talking about chapelle sorry
oh you racing can you imagine being at
this show you're already excited that
you're watching chris rock and kevin
hart and then chabel
comes out
the chappelle opened yeah because
chappelle comes in as a surprise wow
like you're just kind of like damn and
then a goat and then there's a goat
with a the goat closed it
man
you know what i'm making right now slap
me now [ __ ] you know what i mean you
know when me and me
what's the deal with man
standing ovation what would be the goats
jokes what would be the white equivalent
of this it would be like seinfeld and
who
it's already back ooh jim gaffigan
yeah louis ck yeah oh yeah steinfeld
louis ck no what do you mean hey it'll
be louis because he's so controversial i
feel like
dave chappelle's
not david tell though because all these
guys david no dude you're you're you're
taking what i'm saying the wrong way
david tells phenomenal but
you're the all these guys fill stadiums
you know what i mean oh so it would have
to be like big big acts so what rogan
bill
but they do that when it's chappelle
rogan
yeah but i'm saying rogan burr and uh
they have to sell the same amount of
tickets who was the other one
who's the other one that we were talking
about what a show no no no no no you
mentioned seeing billboard again we were
just talking about the bird together
either helicopter
louis rogan louis doesn't do uh arenas
he i think he he could do madison square
garden for sure louis could
yeah he would sell it out
you didn't sales may take his like rogan
and birth no no no well that's what you
said though right no i didn't say that
no he [ __ ] up right i said i have to
do a reading no he [ __ ] up right
i did [ __ ] up i'll admit when i [ __ ] up
no you [ __ ] up right
honey does anybody know what movie
that's from you know you [ __ ] up you
know what medicine society
i like that one don't look over at me
like i'm supposed to know
your shirt
this is a real movie minister society
was like the knock-off version oh wow
wow
wow that's a knock-off first you're
acting like mca didn't have a [ __ ]
song on that soundtrack you act like uh
ice cube's a real actor hold on a second
he is a tremendous actor at this point i
do you know in three games when he's
like can you breathe that was
that's what acting is easy right can you
breathe
yeah but he owns you know the ice cube
is a mogul now yeah dude come on yeah
yeah remember when you oh that's [ __ ]
[Music]
then he brought somebody out
that sounded just like him yeah they're
the same person who made a lot of money
yeah back 10
west side boogie young
owned a backyard boogie yeah
see you next week thursday friday
saturday dallas crystalia.com go get
your tickets dude dickboy.com and then
the tie-dye merch wichita friday baby oh
that's cool wichita wichita [ __ ]
wichita dude i'll be there man wichita
is where the btk killer who got famous
dude that's right so come let's change
history and [ __ ] have crystalline be
the wichita dude instead of bt killer
because that's bad for you guys sure
it's bad it's bad press man and then
chicago one night only august 26th all
right love you guys
eric will be in la jolla i'll be in the
hall your knights
[Laughter]
[Music]
i just probably have to slow it down and
hit it like
this the wing and the king and then
and the sting and the wing